[Music]
foreign
first look at what is on the front pages
as they arrive and it's time to see
what's making the headlines with Claire
Ellicott acting Deputy political editor
at the mail on Sunday and Jasmine
Cameron chileshay who is political
journalist at the financial times
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight thank you very much for
joining us both of you let's see what is
on the front of those newspapers on the
treasury's plans to cut migration to the
UK could result in people paying higher
taxes the eye reports
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt is facing a
backlash from Tory MPS due to his plan
to rise taxes the Ft reports
the times leads are an interview with
Britain's most senior police chief who
says there should be more power to sack
underperforming officers
the telegraph writes at the PM Rishi
sunak is worried about women's safety in
Britain following on from the death of
Zara Alina
The Daily Mail reports on qatar's
decision to ban bear at the world cup
two days before the tournament is to
begin
similarly the mirror leads with the same
story noting how some fans have reacted
negatively to the ban
the sun reports that the husband of I'm
a celebrity winner Jacqueline jossa has
been held on suspicion of gbh
the express says turkey prices are
rising as a result of the recent
outbreak of avian flu
The Daily Star goes with footballers
waxing their legs to cope with the
Qatari Heat
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch along with us well it's not we are
joined by Claire Ellicott and Jasmine
Cameron chillichet great to see you both
uh thank you very much lots and lots to
talk through this evening
um let's start with the Daily Telegraph
and start with you Claire
um we of course on Sky News Tonight
leading on the story of of two women who
were killed by a man and Rishi sunak
talking about his fears for his own
family uh following the murder of Zara
Alina in London
yes so Rishi sunak has two young
daughters and he's actually made the
quite startling admission that he's
frightened about them walking home by
themselves on the streets of Britain
must buy an extraordinary thing to say
and now it comes in the wake of Zara and
Lena's death she was a law graduate who
was walking home last summer
um in London and she was attacked by a
man called Jordan McSweeney who was I
think he was on he was Roman from prison
he should have been in prison and police
officers were trying to track him down
and didn't manage to and um he killed
this young woman and um we all remember
the Sarah everard story as well there
were so many protests across the UK
people were Furious about it and now to
hear the Prime Minister saying that he's
scared for his own daughters is quite an
extraordinary thing to hear
um and I think you know he was speaking
on the way back from
um from Bali from the summit and um he's
also sort of said that more people
should be in prison as a result that
more criminals should be locked up so
it's first Insight we've really had into
Rishi sunax views on crime in the UK
it's interesting isn't it Jasmine the
prime minister's saying he's Fair he
fears for the safety of women of course
many women especially those living in
big cities who have to walk home late at
night know only too well what those
fears feel like
yeah and it's actually quite a striking
admission and it's a rare show of him
sort of giving a deeper insight into his
family life into how he feels about
um you know certain issues because we're
so used to him sort of doubtedly
focusing on on the economy obviously as
you would expect given all the turmoil
that we've had over the past few weeks
but it is important to note that despite
um you know the cost of living crisis
and all the other issues that the
country faces there are still systemic
issues in society especially when it
comes to sexism and violence against
women and so I do think it is
encouraging that he is
um you know openly speaking up about
this but I think what was interesting in
the in the telegraph piece is that there
doesn't really seem to be anything in
the way of tangible Solutions I mean he
said that he supports the prison
population going up but that doesn't
necessarily give any reassurance to you
know women reading the front page as to
thinking you know how is where she seen
that going to improve my life make me
feel safer on the walk home so I think
it gives an insight into his thinking on
the matter but it doesn't necessarily
give a you know a real sense of what the
government's going to practice basically
do to address this that's a good point
and if we move Claire across to the
times they also have a front page about
violence against women and girls but the
new met Police Chief Sir Mark Rowley
talking about he would like it to be
easier to sack police and of course we
had that report just a few weeks ago
that came off the back of the murder of
Sarah everard by a serving policeman and
this suggested that there were many
police officers who shouldn't be in
their jobs and maybe maybe that's the
solution of his eyes get rid of them
yes I mean it's quite quite strong words
from Smart Rowley he's the Met Chief and
um he said that as many as one in ten of
the police Workforce are unfit for Duty
be it because they've had complaints
made against them or because they're not
up to doing the job or their Fitness and
you know General Health and that's quite
extraordinary and I think it he says it
goes up to about one in five of the
Bobbies on the beat the people that we
really care about seeing around and that
really reassure people especially in the
wake of Sarah everard and other sort of
events like that and so his his words
are quite striking and um he's a very
kind of like Back to Basics sort of
policeman he wants police to go out and
investigate every burglary and and he's
clearly trying to reassure people now
that you know those who aren't fit to do
the job and we've seen so many
controversies recently with serving
police officers sharing pictures they
shouldn't and making comments they
shouldn't that you know this is his bid
I think to try to get back on the front
foot and to reassure the public that the
police are on their side Jasmine do you
think confidence has been lost in the
police for many women
certainly and I do think that at the
moment is facing a bit of a credibility
crisis as Claire says there's been lots
of scandals whether it comes to the
sharing of inappropriate images and the
use of language among certain police
officers obviously these are you know
only a handful of very striking cases
but I think it's built up a picture
where many people have really questioned
especially question the leadership of
them are under
um doing crested a dick and so obviously
as the new commissioner he's you know
he's attempting to come in and issue
some quite blunt words about the type of
these officers he wants serving under
him the type of jobs that they should be
doing I think it's also quite
interesting further down in the times
piece it it touches upon the fact that
he wants to set a date at which there
becomes a clear distinction between you
know police officers doing jobs that
perhaps would be more suitable for NHS
workers or social workers as Claire's
saying he's really wanting to bring the
force Back to Basics and you know have a
greater focus on crime but I do
ultimately think you know it's going to
take more than a you know quite a feisty
interview in the times to restore
confidence this is something that will
take a long time time and ultimately it
will be a case of whether the public
feel as though the office on the offices
on the streets are there to genuinely
support them and you know it's something
that can be achieved but I think it will
be a working process at this point
well let's move away from violence
against women and girls back into
politics and of course we had the
awesome statement this week
um the eyes take on it tomorrow Claire
is that the treasury is warning that
this the number 10 plan to cut migration
will actually lead to higher taxes why
is that
well yeah this is really interesting
it's an exclusive that the I have on the
front page
um it sounds like the treasury is
warning that should any attempts be made
to cut the numbers of migrants coming
into the country and therefore the
workforce and taxes will have to go up
now this will all be based on the obr
the Watchdog
um warning that uh well factoring in
that there'll be um 200 000 people
coming to the UK every year and that
making up part of the workforce and that
obviously feeding your money to the
system should you lose any of that you
would inevitably have to put up taxes or
and cut spending and we've already seen
quite a lot of this in the budget and
it's not necessarily landed that well
whether necessary or not and so it is a
kind of Brewing row and um swella Braven
and the Home Secretary is obviously
really opposed to any increase in um
migration and a large proportion of the
public are whenever they're polled so
it's quite a difficult battle the
treasury will ultimately need to balance
the books and this will be their sort of
message and how to do it and Jasmine if
you move across to your paper the
financial times its headline too is
about the Autumn statement isn't it in
Tory MPS hitting out at Hans tax Rises
amid fear of an election route is the
ft's take on it I mean it it it is
unpopular with some Tory MPS isn't it
but
it's not unpopular with all Tory MPS and
there will be certainly others who would
normally sit on the other side of the
political house who will see a lot to to
be pleased at in this
yeah certainly I mean I think overall a
lot of Tory MPS are refraining from
publicly criticizing the statement
because I think there's a genuine a
genuine acceptance of well what else can
the party do even those MPS who are in
favor of low taxes there is a feeling
that actually because of the way in
which trust's low tax vision for the
economy panned out and because of the
way in which markets were rebuked by the
way she communicated her policies and
delivered them many of those who do
believe in that Vision are sort of
sitting out quietly but it has been
interesting to see a handful of voices
namely from the Tory writes who have
come out and their voice concern at you
know some of the high taxes that are
being proposed so I think we've had from
Esther McVay people like Jacob Reese
Mark have also have also spoken out on
opposition but I think what would be
interesting to see is whether those
opposing voices translate into actual
rebellions and votes against the
government I mean I would argue that
actually there isn't any sort of mood
within the back benches to have another
leadership race to ask another leader
and I suspect everyone will eventually
rally behind Rishi sunak and I do think
that's made easier by the fact that some
of the more contentious tax Rises and
public sector Cuts don't come until
after the election so yes certainly
we're seeing some opposing voices coming
out but I think overall there's a real
sense among the party that ultimately
hunt was put in a difficult position and
he did the best that he could do
what do you think that the reaction of
the mail on Sunday readers uh Claire
will be to to this week's financial
statement
yeah I think it'll probably be something
similar to the males I think there is a
danger that
um it looks like a lot of mid-learners
and higher earners have really been
clobbered in this budget and um it's
while necessary and I think what Jasmine
was saying is totally right a lot of
Tory MPS are just going to have to
accept this as you know tough medicine
and it is not going to go down that well
with the public when they start to
notice the difference now as Jasmine
also pointed out a lot of these a lot of
the real pain doesn't come in until the
next election and that puts labor in a
bit of a difficult position as to how it
goes into the election campaign and how
it how it positions itself in terms of
tax Rises and spending cuts
um but yeah I do think the reception to
the budget amount like most of the
newspapers hasn't been that positive and
there is a bit of a concern there hasn't
been you know no one's sort of outline
where growth is coming from and whether
that's a tainted word now following list
trusses experiment who knows but it
there is you know a big concern that
it's not it's not all being positive it
is all sort of grim reading and it is a
lot of pain for taxpayers to put up with
and Jasmine and another um tainted word
that politicians don't like to hear as
strikes but inside the times we're
hearing of more strike chaos looming a
sort of winter of discontent coming up
thousands of civil servants the
department for transport border force
and home office threatening strikes from
mid-December which could really threaten
a lot of people's Christmas travel plans
couldn't it
yes certainly and it also comes at a
time when we know
um nurses are also planning to strike as
well so it really feels like we're
getting this winter of discontent lots
of public sector workers
um voicing their concern about pay in
the lives of rising inflation and the
time then times points out that actually
the the public the civil servants who
are striking could really have an impact
on anyone that's trying to go on holiday
anyone that's trying to renew their
passport and I do think these strikes
are incredibly damaging to the
government because it gives it gives a
sense among the public that the
government isn't really in control it
hasn't really managed to um you know
invest in and support public sector
workers or public services in general
and I think the combination of strikes
people feeling like that their money
isn't going far enough increasing taxes
it just points to a feeling of Decline
and I feel like that feeling is going to
be really politically damaging for the
party at The Ballot Box it does it does
feel doesn't it Claire that we've got
kind of quite a miserable few months
ahead of us for a number of reasons be
it strikes be it energy bills be it the
fact that nobody seems to know what's
happening with the weather and the
climate
yeah no indeed and it does seem like
it'll be quite miserable Christmas all
of these strikes are due to take place
over Christmas and um you know what the
government they're in a difficult
position because a lot of these are from
you know nurses are asking for a 17.6
pay rise and um the airport supports the
unions PCS are asking for a 10 pay rise
inflation's obviously running about 11
and it's just a very difficult situation
and to add to that we've got all the
concerns with bird flu and whether we're
going to have turkeys and eggs then you
know it's still it's not shaping up to
be a great Christmas Is it okay well we
can hope we can maybe we can maybe
moderate our Christmas plans but still
enjoy them uh Clara Jasmine thanks very
much for the time being lots more to
come including what's going on in Casa
they think it's all sober the backlash
from some over beer and the ban on it at
the World Cup
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview and with me this evening Claire
Ellicott acting Deputy political editor
at the mail on Sunday and Jasmine
Cameron Shay political journalist at the
financial times taking us through their
choices and we're going to kick off this
half of Jasmine with the mirror and this
is about qatar's ban on booze at the
venues which had previously been agreed
between FIFA and the sponsor Budweiser
it's not happening the mirrors headline
they think it's all sober
yes so the sale of alcohol is um
strictly controlled in Qatar but there
were some it was it was understood that
actually some alcohol would be would be
sold to fans but obviously now just with
a couple days till the tournament's due
to start that has been changed and this
one actually come as a big blow to fans
you would have already booked tickets
and flights and hotels and were
expecting a certain
um audience experience and now won't be
guessing that and I think there are
questions as to why now I mean this
tournament has been in the works for
literally years and certain guidelines
and expectations have been set so to
change that at the very last minute is a
very odd decision and there are also
questions as to you know there are lots
of um alcoholic alcohol companies that
are sponsoring the the tournament and
where that um you know where the legal
obligations are and I do think that
there are wider questions as to how many
compromises ought to be made over this
tournament we already know that it was
changed from the summer so the winter
there are concerns about
um the experience of lgbtq fans and in
the country and this just feels like one
of many compromises that fans and um you
know fans and guests will have to make
in order to to make this world cup work
I mean I suppose a lot of people would
say you don't need beer to enjoy
football and there were lots of there'll
be lots of fans who are going over there
who won't drink or who won't necessarily
be bothered by this one way or the other
but the timing of it is curious isn't it
oh certainly but really I mean beer and
football just seem to go together don't
they and um Budweiser spent millions of
63 million quid I think um sponsoring
this event that's taken about 12 years
to plan so to be told two days before
it's due to start but they're not able
to serve beer it's quite a shock and
their reaction on Twitter was quite
funny I think they said that was awkward
um and there is there are reports
yes it was quickly deleted
but yes indeed um but there were there
are reports that
um people have paid loads of money for
their tickets and thousands of pounds
for their tickets are able to enjoy
champagne in other areas so it seems a
little bit hypocritical but it does it
goes back to what Jasmine was saying
this whole thing's sort of been shrouded
in a lot of secrecy and there are a lot
of last minute changes there aren't real
concerns about how Katara running this
and whether you know and and the workers
who've been involved in it and um you
know just the whole organization of it
has been quite patchy